major political news cbs is reporting
that joe biden's dog
major will get his very own inauguration
ceremony this sunday
look at them and major is also making
hound history next week becoming
the first rescue pup to set paw in the
white house the delaware humane society
is hosting the virtual
uh dog party which you can attend by
donating 10 bucks to help out other
sweet love pups
find their forever homes um and we
should add that a cat
is said to be joining the white house as
well i have heard that
yes we will stay on top of these details
and bring them to you as they develop
i know it's absolutely true douglas uh
my rescue dog is somewhere over there
dougie come on over here
um speaking of doggies ross um
you know we never want this show to end
so we thought that every day we could
leave you with something
to carry with you so without further ado
please meet the doggy bag
that's right i like that and today's
little tip to go
is the parakon snowball
maker i have to tell you this is no joke
this has changed my life my girls
absolutely love it in fact watch here's
us
slinging snowballs in central park
thank you we're going to build these
snowballs to nail olive oil
now watch out let's run
this weekend ross we did a group of
friends socially distanced math we were
all nines we went for a walk and i am
drew you
dougie was there a little dog yeah and
you forgot a doggie bag for a pickup
different kind of doggy bag and this is
my favorite story if i can tell it but
we were like what are we gonna do
the dog you went and you went up to a
lady well i took
brandon who's like head of our
integrations to get me the uh give me
the idea i was like i see a bag over
there in the corner i'm sure it's clean
but she goes up to this woman's like
excuse me could you have an extra doggie
bag and the woman was so nice by the way
drew covered in a mask and a hat she
looks like this
and the woman they have this nice
conversation she has no idea
drew barrymore just asked her for a
doggie bag for her dog
she had no idea what was you uh this you
know and
yeah and she was just so nice because
she you know
leaving poop in the park is like i mean
it's just the worst
i mean you it is just blasphemy so to
that strange lady
thanks for the bad thank you and to you
guys at home if
you and your friends loved one kid
anybody wants to make a snowball
the density is perfect the throwage
makes them perfect the
spread out when it has contact this is
literally you will never
look at snowballs the same way again and
you'll never want to be without it so
that's today's doggie bag thank you for
[Music]
watching